abone ol
bu hoşgeldiniz
bu Çimen çok uzun yıllardır çok sayıda
evliye eşlik etmiş İyi günlerini kötü
günlerini görmüş Evlenmiş boşanmış
sonrasında danışanları tarafından acaba
terzi söküğünü dikemiyor mu denmiş yahut
hocam tanıdığımız iyi bir Terapist var
İsterseniz telefonu verelim denmiş iyi
günleri ve kötü günleri olmuş İki çocuğu
anası babası kardeşleri Sahici dostları
ve sevdiği adamı olan bir kadınım
hayatından memnun bir kadının
en iyi bizim mevzu ilişki ve evlilik
Fakat burada hani benim dilimin
durmaksızın kadın ve erkek yahut
evliliğe kaymasını dikkate almayın siz
lütfen ilişki zemininden onları okuyun
12 katiyen homofobik okumayı lgbt bir
selam göndereyim mutlak bir biçimde şu
tarihsel bir bakarsak benim jenerasyonum
ve Aslında benden Biraz önceki
jenerasyonun evliliği ve ilişkiyi
öğrenişi Türk filmlerinde mezun şuydu
açık sinemalara gidilir çekirdekçi tilir
bir kız esas kızı esas olan vardır
Bunlar daima sosyo ekonomik olarak
birbirinden farklıdır ve kavuşamazlar
Bare Eğer kavuşabilir ler ise bir yol
olur kavuşabilir ler ise o dakikada film
biter Mesaj şudur evlenildiği ve artık
Bütün problemler hallolur Biz kendi
gençliğimiz boyunca onlar evlendikten
sonra ne olduğunu bir türlü göremedik
daha sonra
ve boşanmalar arttı hasça güncellendi ve
bu defa Biz dizileri seyretmeye başladık
dizilerde abiler var böyle uzaklara
doğru bakıyorlar 50 kelime ile
konuşuyorlar derin olduklarına dair bir
alt mesaj var ki asla sahiden 50 kelime
ile konuşuyorlar ve böyle heyecanlı
hafif Hoca da onların işte eşleri
sevgilileri formatında genç bir kadın
var Ve bu ağır abilerin zillerde ki
vazifesi o genç hanımı hizaya sokmak bu
hikayeden sonradan arsis erkek severlik
şeklinde toplum mühendisliğinin bir
hediyesi ile karşı karşıya kaldık ki Bu
iyi bir şey diye düşünüyorum Şimdi ben
size biriktirdiklerimi anlatacağım çokça
evlilik tanıyorum abi bir kaç bin hepsi
parmak izi gibi anlatacaklarımı hiçbiri
size uymayabilir Pepsi oturabilir size
Uyan alıp uyuyanı bırakmanızı rica
ediyorum Bir Minik anektod dan sonra
başlayacağım evliliğin ya da ilişki
da olabildiğince ilişkiye çevirmeye
çalışacağım 7 Büyük günahı diye bir
hikaye anlatacağım ben sayıları
sevmiyorum Hani 3 şey evliliğin 55 doğru
yolu çocuk yetiştirmenin 25 tane yöntemi
burada biriktirdiklerimi ancak giydiği
sığdırabilirim Geçen gün çocukların bana
dediler ki annene ruhsuzsun burada
oturmakta lar Hayırdır İnşallah dedim
aşk zaten biter deyip duruyorsun her
yerde ne yapacağız bu düşündüm hakikaten
16 yaşındakiler için yahut Kırkında
elindekiler için bilene fena bir bilgi
açık zaten biter
bu korkuya mahluk evladım dedim
yaşanırken farkedilmiyor senin yaşadığın
tamamen farklı bir şey olduğunu
düşünüyorsun zaten düşünüyorsan da aşık
değilsindir şu fazla yerinde demektir
bir şimdi evliliğin 7 Büyük günahı
derken şundan ilişkinin 7 Büyük günahı
derken şundan bahsediyorum Aslında
ilişkiler böyle uzunlamasına giderken
bir sürü yerde tökezliyor lar daha
yaygın tökezlediğiniz hallerden daha
keskindir acılardan bahsediyorum
birincisi Allah rahmet eylesin bir an
son profesördür sağ Mizan bir amfide
koca bir amfide ders verir Facebook'ta
bir adamdır ve derslere sıklıkla da
şöyle başlar sene başında der ki
kızlarım lafım size koca terbiye edilmez
terbiyeli sağlanır bu
bu burada hani bu elbet erkeklere de
söylenebilir hikayedir ama kadınların
cebinde partnerleri ile ilgili iddialı
bir değiştirecekler listesi vardır
yaptım Biliyorum çokça yapanı da
tanıyorum aynı zamanda denir ki
değiştireceğiniz kimseyle değiştirmek
isteğinizin olduğu hiç kimseyle
evlenmeyin uzunlamasına ilişkiye
girmeyin yeni jenerasyonun tarifiyle
takılabilir siniz o ayrı mevzu
en iyi Peki değişmeyecek miyiz Yani
adamı aldık böyle dondu kaldı bitti mi
ya ya değil Herkes değişiyor mutlak
değişiyor önünde durulabilir bir şey
değil değişmiş Fakat eğer sizin bir
isteğiniz olursa insanın kendi olağan
seyrine önüne geçiyorsunuz bir proje
haline getirsin Çünkü benlik ve bünye
doğal olarak direnç koyuyor ve kendini
koruyor burada bir ikinci tarif var bunu
hastayım diyor ki bir kadın ve adamın
ilişkisi kimyasal bir tepkime benzer
Eğer tepkime gerçekleşirse Her ikisi de
kılık değiştirir bu şu demek Gönül
gönüle değerse zaten o değişim kendi
seyir ve süreci içinde olur bu 1 2.
madde köken aileler en çok çok
özlediğimiz yerlerden biri ilişkilerde
evliliklerde şimdi Biz memlekete ait
böyle çok alt dinamiklere sahip bir
coğrafyada eğer biz bu gün bu toplantıyı
osto da yapıyor olsaydık
en geniş bahsetmeye olacaktık Onlar
zaten çocuklar 18'inde postalanmış
olacaklardı ve daha bireysel insanlar
olacaktık iyi kötü ayrı hikaye ama bu
coğrafyada biz özellikle şmesi daha az
köken ailelerle Bağları daha fazla
iddialı sosyal destekler alan ve bununla
ilgili de bir takım böyle bedeller
ödeyen hallerdeyiz asıl köken aile
derdinin daha az Afilli söylenişi şudur
kayınvalide gelin problemi burada hikaye
şudur ortada bir tane Adamcağız vardır
Hakikaten de Adamcağız drama bir
tarafında ona yıllarını vermiş anne öbür
tarafında ona geleceği vaat eden kadın
burada yapılacak temel mesela adam
ortadan pılı pırtıyı toplayacak gidecek
mutlak bir biçimde ve o iki kadın
birbirleriyle ilişki kurmayı
öğrenecekler burada daima genç olanı
performansının daha iddialı ve başarılı
olması beklenir Burası bataklık alandır
çok olağanüstü dikkat etmeliyiz
bu Herkesin kendi ailesiyle bulduğu
ilişkideki sınıra parmağımızın ucunu
toplamayı öneririm Elbette ki
geliştireceğiz olgun aşacağız bu
ilişkilerde değişecek sevmeye çalışmanın
çok kıymetli olduğunu düşünüyorum ben
parkların ailesinin epey geçirmeye gönlü
olmanın mayanız tutmayabilir tutmadıysa
da Nezaket in çok yukarıda olması
lazımdır geldik 3. günaha cinsellik
cinsellik günah değil cinselliği imal
edilmesi fena günah ilişkilerde ve
evliliklerdeki en hızlı irtifa kaybeden
alanlardan bir tanesi cinsellik bir kere
memleketin bu konudaki sakası çok
evlenilecek ve eğlenilecek kadın
terminolojiler
her yere bakarak yürümenin edepli olduğu
coğrafya erkeklerin cinselliği algı
dışındaki o performans kaygısı yanı sıra
da bunu bir performans sanatı gibi
algılayışları tabi uzunlamasına giden
evlilik formatındaki ilişkilerde
eskilerin fingirdemek dediği bizim flört
etmek dediğimiz hikaye çok kıymetli icin
Selin Aslında ilk üçteki Sarsılmaz yeri
bir kadın ve adam ilişkisinde olan
sürecinde Kıymet zaten bir arada
oluşları bir kadın ve adam olmakla
ilgilidir ve cinsellikle bunun altın çok
bol çizen hallerden biridir kadının o
Saygın Ve saygıdeğer olmakla ilgili
Coğrafyadan gelen ve Aslında epey
sakatlanmış olan hikâyesinden kurtulması
bir vakit alır yıllar önce Yanılmıyorsam
ikinci ya da üçüncü deneyimin çift
görmeye başladığında 50'li yaşlara yakın
bir beyefendi ve eşi var hanfendi
boşalmak istiyor ve efendi hayatta Koşan
Sen niye dedik memlekette kadın kadın
olur yaşı kırkı bulur dedi ben bunu
Yıllar sonra yıllar İçerisi 20 yıl
önceden bahsediyorum mükerrer kere
düşündüm Hani Aslında o kendinizi
serbest bırakıldı Bu da kışın ızla
ilgili uzun bir vakit geçer yeni
jenerasyonun bu konuda daha hoyrat
olduğunu düşünüyorum cinsellik konusunda
daha nesnel olduğunu düşünüyorum ama
kendi bedenleri konusunda daha sağlıklı
olduğunu düşünüyorum Aynı zamanda 4
şimdi ilişkilerin sıkı tökezledi
yerlerden biri Aslında dünyada bizim
coğrafyada en sert tökezledi yere beyin
olunan vakit anne baba olmakla karı koca
ya da kadın erkek olmak yüzünden epey
ayrı haller hiç benzemiyorlar neredeyse
ve bebeğin İşte bu kutsal atıkları olan
bir hikaye Dolayısıyla ilişkinin üstünü
geliyor sarıyor bir vakit sonra siz
kendinizi saze bebeğin gibi görmeye
başlıyorsunuz eski jenerasyonlar Bunu
bilir Buna da Fi
bu tarz yok Yeni jenerasyon mutlu olmak
ve haz almak konusunda iddialı ve
iddaacı buralarda o kaybedilen Has
ilişkinin en sert tökezleme lerinden
Biri haline geliyor yurtdışında bazı
terapi merkezleri biri doğum sonrası 3-4
yıl içinde gördüğü vakit çifti yalnız
zaman geçirme kontratı olmadan görmüyor
müsabakalar en çok doğumdan sonraki ilk
dörtlü içinde boşanıyorlar Çünkü o denge
sarsılıyor katiyen ve katiyen bu
hatların birbiriyle hiçbir bağlantısı
neredeyse olmadığını iyi görmemiz gerek
buralarda iki şey önemli bir çocuksu
zaman geçireceğiz çok kıymetli iki
birbirimizin ebeveyni ile müdahale
etmeyeceğiz herkesin Bahtına bir Anneyle
baba düşüyor Bu da oturan iki evladımın
Bahtına Ben düşmüş durumdayım günün
sonunda iyisi kötüsü doğrusu eğrisi baş
edecekler Eğer özel bir Mar eziyet yoksa
birbirimizi ne benliğinden pu
Bu bir toplayıp çıkaracağız herkes
usulünce ebeveynlik yapacak Kendi
usulünce hani magazinel bir biçimde
çocuğu aynı şeyi söylememiz gerekiyor
efsanesinden bir kurtulacağız Elbette
ortaklık yapmamız gereken alanlar var
ama tamamen ayrı hatlarda gidiyoruz Ben
epey Bu anlamda dert yaşamış insan
tanırım geldik 4 doğru mu 125 en büyük
günah açık ara en büyük günah içgörü en
basit karşılığı Aslında kendini bilmek
demek iç yürümez usu boyu hayat
dediğiniz hikaye kendinden insan yaratma
macerası dır ya bu macerada aslında
cebinizdeki en kıymetli malzeme Kendimiz
için ilişkimiz için çoluğumuz çocuğumuz
için yas Her şey için çok kıymetli
hikayenin dibinde ve temelinde oturan
mezunu ilişkideki içgörü de birkaç tane
sorun çok iyi cevaplanması lazım ilişki
içgüdüsünün entem
ya Ben Nerde Yanlış yapıyorum dur Fakat
bu sorunun cevabı Çok iyi niyetliyim O
yüzden hata yapıyorum samimiyet Sizinde
bir cevap değil Burada üç soru var bir
niye evleniyorum bu adamla öbürüne değil
de bununla ya da bu kadınla iki nerede
Dert yaşıyorum 3 yaşadıklarımda benim
rolüm nedir
Evet şimdi niye evlendiğiniz ya da niye
Aşk hissettiğimiz O şahsiyete sevdiğiniz
sorusunun cevabı karma karışıktır
ihtiyaçlarımız tercihlerimizi belirliyor
ihtiyaçlarımız değişebiliyor bu defa
tercihimiz aynı şekilde Şemal için de
değişmeye biliyor Birsel adamla çok
canlı diye evleniyoruz Eve hiç girmiyor
diye boşanıyoruz yahut kadınla beni çok
değerli ya topluyor Şahane hayatıma
müthiş bir düzen getirdi diye
evleniyoruz ve anne kadın istemiyorum
daha canlı birini istiyorum diye
boşanıyoruz hikayenin burasında
ihtiyaçlarda değişiyor dolayısıyla da
eğer o değişen ihtiyaçlarla beraber
Partner ve ilişkide böyle benzer bir
ahenkte değişirse ne ala yoksa işimiz de
iddialı zorluklar var Bir ilişkide
yaşanan Dertlerin sayısını çıkarmak
olası değil hani buradan bugün konuşmaya
başlayıp Bir ay sonra bitirsek geçmez
ve iletişim kuramıyoruz beni seviyor
beni sevmiyor ailesiyle ilgili derdim
var duygusunu çok aktarıyor hiç
aktarmıyor benimle çok ilgileniyor hiç
ilgilenmiyor çok arka bahçesi var hiç
arka bahçesi yok kocaman çok kişisel
burada parmak izi gibi her çiftin tarifi
farklı şu üçüncü sorunun cevabı benim
için çok kıymetli Ben nerede hata yaptım
ilişkilerine yapıyorum yanlış cümle
şimdi bu soru çiftlerle görüşürken
şu dananın kuyruğunun koptuğu yerdir
nedir sizin kattınız dersiniz bu olup
biten hikaye eder ki iki çok
sinirlendiriyor beni işte çok küsüyor
borç ok iletişimsiz peki eyvallah Siz ne
yapıyorsunuz Dersin ne yapıyorum ama
diye başlayan cümleler olur ama ile
başlayan her gerekçe patinaj dır Gerisi
de hikayedir yani adam bağırıyor
durkadın küsüyor dur bağırdığı için
küsüyorum küstüğü için bağırıyorum bu
dehlizden çıkılmaz bir hikaye ancak
şöyledir yanlış yapıyorum bağırıyorum
ayrı bir hikayedir yanlış yapıyorum
küsüyorum ayrı bir hikayedir ilişki iç
görürsün de herkes kendi ile ilgili
yüksek samimiyet ile kendine dair olanı
bulmak da mükelleftir Hayat içinde
mükellefiz bunda yani doğru muz var
evimiz var ucuz yanımız var Zayıf
yanımız var geldik 6'da iletişim
Evet şimdi hayatını dinleyerek ve
konuşarak kazanan biriyim konuşmayı da
seven biriyim Üstelik buna rağmen Son
zamanlarda böyle hani duyduğum zaman
beni rahatsız eden kelimelerden Biri
haline geldi iletişim iletişimin tabi
üstatları var kelimelere takla
attıranlar var Şahane yapanlar var fakat
iletişimde çok kıymetli bir Dipnot var
onun pas geçilmesi hikaye çok
zorlaştırıyor şimdi iletişim şu ben size
anlatıyorum Siz beni anlamıyorsunuz
şöyle siz anlatıyorsunuz ben de
anlıyorum Şahane katiyen Uzlaşmak
durumunda değiliz fakat kullandığımız
kelimeler arttıkça ve biz Aslında
iletişimi Bir performans sanatı gibi yön
etmeye başladıkça iletişim anlattığım
anlaşılır ve kabul edilir hikâyesine
Doğru böyle büyük bir hızla ilerlemekte
şifre arasındaki iletişimde şu tarifi
çok kıymetli olduğunu düşünüyorum ben
ulaşamayacağınız alanlar olduğu
konusunda uzlaşma mısınız bu
O bir adam ayrı alt kültürler ayrı ayrı
ayrı ayrı ve her alanda uzlaşmaya
kalktıkları zaman yani iletişimin sihir
olduğunu iletişimleri zaman illaki
ulaşacakları gibi bir alt bilgiye sahip
oldukları vakit bir adım sonrasında
restleşme başlıyorlar yok bizim en
yaygın gördüğümüz bataklıktır
ve dolayısıyla iletişim kıymetli insan
sözle gözle görülür bir sürü şeyle
iletişimdir doğru-yanlış iletişimdir
velev ki uzlaşma ihtimali cebinde
tutmalıdır ve 7 Ve benim en sevdiğim
madde Ben şimdi evliliğin akıllı bir şey
olduğunu düşünmüyorum Gayet net evliliği
seviyorum ya oynuyorum Hani çocuklarıma
en az bir kere evlenmelerini öneririm ve
herkese sonrasını ve devamını bilmem ama
herkesin mutlak deneyimlemesi
gerektiğini düşünürüm evli olma halini
fakat akıllı bir hikaye olduğunu
Külliyen düşünüyorum yani aynı hayat
aynı insanlar aynı yatak aynı ev Aynı
aynı aynı ve bunun içinden beklediğimiz
iddialı bir haz var aynı zamanda ve
fakat Bu hikayede bütün bu hayal
kırıklıklarına rağmen yıllardır devam
edebiliyor duysa başka bir şeye hizmet
ediyor olmalı daha derinde bir hayali
olmalı az ulaşılan bir hayali
Bu pek az çiftin yakalaya bildiği ama
daha derin bir hevesi olmalı evliliğin
evliliğin katiyen bir akıl oyunu değil
istek oyunu olduğunu düşünmekteyim ben
insanın Hani Dünya ile ilişkisinde
aktardık larından daha başkasını daha
değerini daha zarfını daha
yetersizliğini asıl krizi edilmeden
parçalanmadan reddedilme den
isteyebileceği bir adres gönül gönül
yarenli istiyor ahbabını istiyor kendini
doğrusuyla eğrisiyle kabul buyuracak
olanını istiyor evliliğin dolaşmak
istediği yer burası pek azımız
dolaşıyoruz ve Fakat fantezinin burası
olduğunu düşünüyorum şimdi bir baştan
sayalım günahları bir değiştireceğimiz
kişiyle evlenmiyoruz
12 biriyle evlenmek aynı zamanda ona ile
dinamiği ile evlenmek demektir maharetli
ve dikkatli oluyoruz aile ilişkilerinde
3 cinsellik daima ilk üçteki Sarsılmaz
yerini koruyacak çok kıymetli 44
evliliğe Bey niye satmıyoruz ikisi
birbirinden ayrı haller 55 içgörü çok
mühim insan olmamızın Aslında yolculuğu
içerisinde olan sürece de miyim ve
olmadan olmaz olmadan en olmayacak hal
olduğunu düşünürüm ben kendimizi
bilmeden yola devam etme şansımız yok
altı iletişim içeceğiz hiç itirazım yok
ve fakat uzlaşma ihtimali de cebimizde
bulun duracağız 7 evlilik bir akıl oyunu
değil istek oyunudur Efendim yolunuzun
yönünüzü ve gönlünüzün açık olmasını
dileriz